if you sleep with someone and you feel
that you have to put hot sauce
in your condom why are you sleeping
but the question is i just don't think
women face consequences i think that's
why like men are more abused because we
don't we don't face consequences for
doing it and just like this that's not
illegal
for a girl to take a condom
and you might be like why would you
sleep with a girl like that but as a guy
he's a lottery ticket for a woman even
even he knows that though he knows his
position
and i think as a man when you're a catch
or a prize man
you have the pick of the letter you can
choose anybody so should he say celibate
yes he will he has not stopped
as a man you should be disciplined and a
disciplined man can get far in life and
he doesn't he has to deal with a lot of
things he has to deal with a lot of
things and this is the problem she's not
so funny
they kind of lack discipline when it
comes to certain behaviors you say
you don't understand a man's nature you
know for you to say that you don't
really understand a man's nature because
um yeah when men like general
generally a man's nature yeah is to have
sex yes it's general nature but the
thing is when you get put in a position
of power
you as a woman would have no idea
the amount of women that are coming for
that man of power as a matter of fact
tiger woods can be married all married
men regardless of how much power they
hold they've got a bunch of women that
are just looking to have sex with that
man and so men
being men yeah in positions of power
sometimes
they say okay i'll take the option it
doesn't mean because you took the option
that you now have to have um in these
days and times that you now have to have
a baby
but he was he was responsible too he's
right he used a condom he wore a condom
and and why why are we putting this on
the women around the med why don't we
put this on the women why are we acting
like home so like where are we why are
we acting like hoes why are you sleeping
right so basically what it is because
you're confused by the thing so
basically he obviously ejaculating in
the condom but afterwards he put hot
sauce in there to basically kill the
sperm and then threw it in the trash but
the woman went in the trash
took a condom out and tried to push it
inside of her and burnt up her thing and
had he not done that she would have had
a baby by him and he would have said if
you if you play it out nine months down
the line he would have said there's no
way that woman's pregnant for my bit for
my opinion because i use a condom
however once she done the dna test it
would have had his dna and they would
have said drake you're talking lies
because the bottom line is she's got
your dna but so he would have looked
like the liar yeah so
you guys think sorry but do you guys
think that because we had a conversation
other day was saying like women like to
fight for social justice right and
eventually that helps to change laws why
do men not stand up when things are
happening to them and speak up about it
and have those laws changed it should be
illegal for a woman to take a condom and
shove it up herself and have a baby it
should be legally
maybe it's because it's hard to prove
yeah
is it record
i'm so caught up she went in the bin
sorry go ahead
no it's not just that as
as women it's
it's innate in us for us to be able to
talk about
whatever it is you can sit around and
talk about someone you
talk about something with someone you've
known for maybe an hour five minutes
however it is as for men
it's not innate in them to be able to
sit down with their friends like hey yo
this this this this because
it's just
i don't i don't know it's just something
that has been
just shown like oh mention and talk
mention and talk about this mention it
gossip like women around the table but
they do though in private men have real
conversations with their boys about the
women that they're engaging with or do
you know her oh i'm talking to this girl
blah blah they want their friends
opinions as well because if they're
dating a girl or linking her imagine
your boys are saying saying oh that
girl's clapped or she's nasty or
whatever but that's different from
that's different from talking about
issues a lot of men don't talk about the
issues that they have they can talk
about females all day talk about working
out this that in the third psychology no
you know jesus is right because i went
to a
it was called
mantle actually it was in brixton
and i remember those
some professionals up there and they
were discussing about men issues
and it was only till i talked about my
issue
of
the mother not allowed me to see my
daughter the whole energy changed in the
room and there was other men that came
up and started speaking even the two of
the panels that was talking about other
addictions and other issues that they
had didn't feed it upon themselves to
talk about how they seen that child or
the
parental alienation they were facing so
you're writing the zac in terms of what
jessica just said it's i've noticed even
from the back of as i said my podcast
and people have seen
a lot of fathers have reached out to me
that i've been surprised and so wow i've
been going through this and they've
wanted to know what things to do
to actually start to see their children
you know it's really deep um it's a
serious subject so i would again have to
say i appreciate your poem you know sort
of talking on it you know what's
interesting
so
when i talk about a situation where the
woman is completely in the wrong right
there there's we no one on this panel
would say
that the girl with the hot sauce
situation was in the right like we all
agree she was wrong
but we automatically put the blame onto
men and we say oh well you shouldn't be
dealing with that but earlier when she
was talking about a situation
where she was in it like like he was
completely in the wrong nobody says oh
well you shouldn't have been dealing
with him exactly like can i pause but
yeah when i went on the podcast
the amount of disgusting comments
that were written under that podcast i
was told that um
god is going to punish me and i chose to
open my legs and just all these
different things i chose the wrong man i
wanted this person that was like this
and
x y and z without actually understanding
the layers of the situation when i met
this person i was 16 he was a good eight
years older than me
that in itself does not tell you
something
but for whatever reason i was getting
all these comments online at me
that
and again it comes to this whole
protection aspect the way i looked at it
was i was 16 and young and i was
in a situation where i felt like he was
protecting me
really
he took advantage of the situation and
that is what led on to whatever happened
over the years but when i went on the
podcast what i found quite disappointing
was the fact that
i was attacked online and
not many people in the comments stood up
for me and this is the issue i feel like
when women do come out and speak
so
it's okay for celebrities to speak but
when real people speak
it's like a oh my gosh well you should
have seen the red flags and you should
have done this and you should have done
that well i i think it's just like a
level of accountability you know like
like the same way we were holding like
the manic like like to me that that's
the same but i don't think that's the
norm i mean i cannot add
just to say when you were speaking you
said you know you said celebrities and
then real people and that that concept
in people's mind that's what it is they
separate celebrities from real people
so when i said about drake
the reasons i said that is because he
already had a child in those similar
circumstances do you get what i mean so
him still um putting himself in a
position with oh no he put the hot
get that but sauce still but the thing
is regardless of hot sauce or not you're
putting yourself in that position
furthermore the fact that the media has
it to talk about you're putting ideas in
people's head you're actually putting
the idea out into the e4 okay and i find
that why i should do that yeah i think
that a lot of these behaviors that we're
seeing with young women in
um young women and men
is it's coming from the fact that the
media kind of projects it into the space
and circulates it on a
a crazy hyper basis but can you imagine
the level of
paranoia
you have to be going through
every time you have sex as drake to
think damn did i put the hot sauce on
the condom this time do you know what i
mean and i think it's unfortunate that
the times in which we live in going back
to the book that i actually said talking
about how to destroy a man
whether or not
the fact that that book exists
i don't know how many women have read it
you don't know how many women have read
it
ish doesn't know how many people have
read it like we just don't know how many
women have read it so it's like
is it now time to protect ourselves well
you know what i think would stop a lot
of this if men could do a financial
abortion
women women have the right not to be a
parent
so so i think like a lot of these girls
are doing this because they're trying to
get a check
so if that happened if there was a
financial abortion sorry speaking to the
mike please imagine if men could say
right yes i had sex with this woman but
i don't want to be responsible for the
child if there becomes a child
how many more single parents would well
women do that they say i yes i hooked up
with this man but i don't want to be a
mom i'm going to kill it
they can do that up to six months he's
truly true
so if we can if we can do that then [ __ ]
then he should be able to do the same
thing
but the man and we shouldn't be doing
that's what they're saying but the man
you control having the child or not so
he can't do it he might get you pregnant
but you have the power to
exactly no i don't believe in that
statement i don't believe men get women
pregnant know what i mean
no absolutely it's 100 the fault of the
woman if you get pregnant if you get
pregnant that's on you as a woman 100
percent it's not a man
so i'll tell you how i'll explain how
i'll explain how so the first time i
heard that i was like
what do you mean but if you think about
it
who knows
when you're like the time that you're
fertile
yeah the woman does he gets
sorry it's your job if you if you don't
want to get pregnant if you don't want
to um
if you don't want to get pregnant period
is your job to voice that to the man
and then if he and certain obviously in
certain situations there's
there's things that happen to where
a woman gets pregnant and
it wasn't
it was just a message
every woman is head of security for
their own vagina
every woman is head of security right
and the only the only if it's not a
great situation
you let somebody in
just like there's a door here
if it's not a burglar situation
someone let someone into this place and
hang on and hang on and the
responsibility for letting if you didn't
vet the person properly or if they
didn't show their id and you believed it
you didn't look at the id that's on you
because once they run up in your house
and burgle your house that's going to be
on you you have to be hang on but no but
you have to be
head of security for your own vagina and
so if you keep letting men who are not
worthy up into your vagina and shooting
up your club that's your that's on you